>>RUNAWAY JUDGES VERSUS THE
TRUMP AGENDA.
THAT'S THE FOCUS ON TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TODAY AT CPAC, THE PRESIDENT
RALLIED THE CONSERVATIVE
FAITHFUL AND URGED THEM NOT TO
LET UP AS THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
APPROACHED.
>> DON'T BE COMPLACENT, BECAUSE
IF THEY GET IN, THEY WILL REPEAL
YOUR TAX CUTS, THEY WILL PUT
JUDGES IN THAT YOU WOULDN'T
BELIEVE, THEY'LL TAKE AWAY YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT, WHICH WE WILL
NEVER ALLOW TO HAPPEN.
>> JUDGES MATTER.
LET'S TAKE GUN LEGISLATION.
NOW, EVEN IF THE PRESIDENT AND
SUCCESSFUL IN PRESSING HIS
AGENDA, JUDGES WITH RADICAL
OUTLOOKS CAN UNDO IT ALL.
THIS IS WHY IT'S SO CRITICAL FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO NOMINATE AND
SEEK CONFIRMED AS MANY JUDGES AS
POSSIBLE ON BOTH THE DISTRICT
AND APPELLATE COURTS.
SINCE TRUMP TOOK OFFICE, CHECK
THIS OUT, MAJOR INITIATIVES HAVE
BEEN STALLED OR STOPPED
ALTOGETHER BY THE COURTS,
INCLUDING HIS TRAVEL BAN, HIS
PLANS TO WITHHOLD FUNDS FROM
THOSE SANCTUARY CITIES, AND HIS
PLAN TO END OBAMA-ERA OIL AND
GAS EMISSION REGULARS.
AND LET'S NOT THE PEOPLE SERVING
IN THE MILITARY.
SO JUST HIS FIRST NINE IN MONTHS
IN OFFICE, CITIES OR STATES
FILED 24 LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO
NOW, A FEW WEEKS AGO, A JUDGE
BLOCKED PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DECISION TO END OBAMA'S DACA
PROGRAM.
HE'S THE SECOND FEDERAL JUDGE TO
DO SO.
NOW, THE JUDGE IS AN INTERESTING
CHARACTER.
WHEN THE DACA CASE LANDED ON HIS
BENCH LAST YEAR, HE CLAIMED THIS
THE PRESIDENT'S ENDING THE DACA
PROGRAM WAS ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS.
GRACIAS, JUDGE.
OF THIS JUDGE HAS A HISTORY OF
EDITORIALIZING FROM THE BENCH
AND IT ENDS UP BEING LIKE
LEGISLATING FROM THE BENCH.
AMERICANS DIDN'T ELECT THE JUDGE
TO CHANGE OUR IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
HE WAS APPOINTED TO BE A CHECK
ON OTHER BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT,
NOT A REPLACEMENT FOR THEM.
SO IF HE WANTS TO GET INTO
LEGISLATING, HE SHOULD TAKE OFF
HIS LONG BLACK ROBE, POUND THE
PAVEMENT, AND THEN RUN FOR
OFFICE.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS ISN'T THE
FIRST TIME THAT THAT JUDGE
CROSSED THE LINE.
IN 2012, HE IMPOSED RACIAL QUOTA
IN 2012, HE IMPOSED RACIAL QUO A
QUOTAS ON THE FIRE DEPARTMENT.
NOW, DECLARING THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT A BASTION OF WHITE
MALE PRIVILEGE, HE REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT TO HIRE TWO BLACK
FIREFIGHTERS AND ONE HISPANIC
FOR EVERY FIVE HIRED.
NOW, PARTS OF HIS RULING WERE
LATER VACATED BY THE APPEALS
COURT THAT QUESTIONED HIS
IMPARTIALITY.
THEY BARRED HIM FROM PRESIDING
FROM FUTURE TRIALS RELATING TO
THE CASE.
HIS LIBERAL BIAS WAS THAT
OBVIOUS.
HE SAT ON THE BENCH AND
REPEATEDLY SLAMMED THE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS RECURRING REDUNDANT DRUM
BEAT OF ANTI-LATINO COMMENTARY.
NOW, COME ON, HE WAS BLATANT IN
HIS DISDAIN FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS POLICIES.
THEN THE CHIEF JUDGE OF THE
FOURTH CIRCUIT COURT OF PEAL --
APPEALS, ROGER GREGORY -- NOW,
IT'S THE SECOND TIME THE FOURTH
CIRCUIT HAS PULLED THIS ROUTINE.
THIS TIME HE CLAIMS THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S TRAVEL RESTRICTION
ON SIX LARGELY MUSLIM COUNTRIES
IS UNCONSTITUTIONALLY TAINTED
TOWARD ISLAM.
FOR 285 UNBELIEVABLY TWISTED
PAGES.
THE RULING TRIES TO TURN TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN RHETORIC INTO A LEGAL
ARGUMENT.
GREGORY WRITES THAT THE TRAVEL
BAN DESCRIPTION WITH RELIGIOUS
INTOLERANCE AND DISCRIMINATION.
THEY SAY THE BAN IS AN ATTEMPT
TO ESTABLISH A NATIONAL RELIGION
THAT CONCLUDES MUSLIMS.
THAT'S WHAT THE THE FOURTH
CIRCUIT RULED.
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT HOLDS UP AT
THE SUPREME COURT, WHICH JUST
ANNOUNCED IT WILL REVIEW THESE
TRAVEL BAN DECISIONS ON APRIL
25TH.
POLITICAL GRANDSTANDING BY
JURISTS, THE TYPE WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT, WHETHER FROM THE BENCH OR
PUBLIC FORUMS, ALL OF THAT ENDS
UP UNDERMINING CONFIDENCE IN THE
COURTS AND IT CERTAINLY
COMPROMISES OUR VIEW OF AN
IMPARTIAL JUDICIARY.
AND THAT GOES FOR THE NOTES RBG
GINSBURG AS WELL.
THE LEFT WANTS TO DO THROUGH THE
COURTS WHAT THEY COULDN'T
ACHIEVE AT THE BALLOT BOX.
IT'S SO TRANSPARENT TO ME.
OBAMA KNEW THIS GAME.
HE WAS ABLE TO STACK THE FEDERAL
BENCH WITH 334 JUDGES.
CLINT APPOINTED 387 JUDGES.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, WELL, HE
UNDERSTANDS THE THREAT POSED BY
AN ACTIVIST JUDICIARY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD TO DEAL
WITH ACTIVIST JUDGES WORKING
AGAINST HIM EVER SINCE HE TOOK
OFFICE.
>> I'LL BE CRITICIZED BY THEM
FOR SPEAKING HARSHLY ABOUT OUR
COURTS.
THIS NEW ORDER WAS TAILORED TO
THE DICTATES OF THE NINTH
CIRCUIT, IN MY OPINION, FLAWED
RULING.
THIS IS, IN THE OPINION OF MANY,
AN UNPRECEDENTED JUDICIAL
OVERREACH.
>> NOW, THERE ARE CURRENTLY 147
VACANCIES ON THE FEDERAL COURTS,
122 IN THE DISTRICT COURTS AND
17 AT THAT IMPORTANT APPELLATE
LEVEL.
A RECORD 12 APPEALS COURT
JUDGES.
OBAMA ONLY GOT THREE IN HIS
FIRST YEAR, SO THAT'S REALLY
GOOD.
A LOT OF WORK REMAINS TO BE
DONE.
THE ONLY WAY TO COUNTER, IS FOR
TRUMP TO FILL THE BENCH WITH HIS
OWN JURISTS, MEN AND WOMEN WHO
STAY WITHIN THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
BOUNDARIES.
MEANWHILE, WE'LL CONTINUE ON
THIS SHOW TO EXPOSE THE